deep sea fishing accounts for just one
percent of fish landed in the North East
Atlantic but a habitats and ecosystems
of these fish are fragile and stocks are
depleting on Monday MEP s from the
fisheries committee voted to adopt new
rules on deep-sea fishing in the North
Atlantic a game-changing moment for the
deep blue sea the measures we are going
to decide upon today are going to make
the difference between losing these very
important and rare species of the very
deep seas or making this face a
sustainable having these faces for the
future cultural and creative industries
are set to get in almost 1.5 billion
euro boost under the creative Europe
program the aim is to better support
people working in TV film culture and
performing arts by training and funding
so the European culture can reach new
audiences through Europe and beyond we
are living in a world with a new ed
visual sector a vision you with new
technologies and we should take care of
it and you should help European
industries to go forward not to wait
that the others are doing everything
that we are running in behind the way to
adopt the drums report takes place on
Tuesday writers musicians performers and
authors all use copyright collectives to
license their work and collect royalties
on their behalf with laws vary from
country to country plans were put in
place to better manage these copper and
collectives and improve multi
territorial licensing but the devil is
in the detail des jeux de cuando de
sobra question dos con appellate sir a
party sub set a deal in endotoxin pursue
me que no son para descubrir pasco on
occupied on TV region for sale or
varmint no no legislation agopian so
keen existe don't colon back versus you
take total association collective down
your open function soul men Modell